si la parole est un monsieur charles de
la verpillière merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'agriculture l'année 2016
aura été très difficile pour nos
agriculteurs en raison des mauvaises
conditions climatiques
conjugué à la baisse du prix des
principales denrées
je voudrais appeler votre attention sur
un aspect particulier de la crise
agricole à savoir la prolifération de
l'influenza aviaire plus connu sous le
nom de grippe aviaire
elle revient régulièrement depuis une
dizaine d'années avec des mutations du
virus hautement pathogène le h5n1
auparavant le h5 n 8
aujourd'hui la découverte de foyers
voire même la simple suspicion d'une
infection cause des dommages
considérables aux élevages de canards et
de volaille les départements de
production infectés sont situées sur le
trajet des oiseaux migrateurs tarn ger
ger ce pardon haute-garonne aveyron
landes le département de l'ain avec la
bresse et la dombes est pour l'instant
épargné mais nous sommes vigilants
monsieur le ministre les indispensables
mesures de prévention et de lutte
confinement abattage interdiction des
transports ont un coût important pour
les éleveurs
au delà c'est toute la filière aval qui
est touchée par la diminution de la
production et la perte de débouchés à
l'exportation sur ce sujet important
j'ai donc trois questions à vous poser
monsieur le ministre
où en est l'épidémie quelles mesures le
gouvernement at-il prises ou envisage
t-il
quelle indemnisation ou compensations
seront accordées aux éleveurs
je vous remercie merci la parole est à
monsieur stéphane le foll ministre de
l'agriculture de l'agroalimentaire et de
la forêt
monsieur
monsieur le président monsieur le député
d'abord je voudrais vous dire que la
question vous avez posé et avec les
précisions vous avez apporté mérite
évidemment des réponses et aussi des
précisions
on est sur un virus h5 enuite
extrêmement virulent et d'après les
vétérinaires du ministère de
l'agriculture que j'ai eu souvent au
téléphone c'est la première fois qu'on a
des taux de mortalité et une rapidité de
la mortalité aussi importante
ce qu'on avait connu l'an dernier sur la
zone de production du sud ouest et qui
nous avait conduit un vide sanitaire
était un autre virus de type h5n1 9
virus liés à la production elle-même et
qu'il était nécessaire d' éradiquer par
un vide sanitaire donc on est sur deux
virus différents qui s'appelle influença
aviaire mais qui n'ont pas ni les mêmes
souches me l'a même virologie à partir
de là on est condamné à prendre des
mesures
d'abord lorsque nous découvrons un foyer
il y en a 19 aujourd'hui en france c'est
l'abattage des animaux infectés
immédiatement un périmètre de sécurité
de 10 km autour pour éviter toute
transmission
il se trouve que dans sur ce sujet les
mesures de biosécurité seront appliquées
avec toute la sévérité nécessaire sur
l'ensemble du territoire puisque nous
sommes en zone élevé maintenant une
protection élevée puisque vous le savez
13 pays européens sont touchés par ce
virus aujourd'hui et on a des abattages
massifs dans des pays européens
il faut tout faire pour éviter la
transmission des foyers vers d'autres
productions
et puis en même temps il ya des
décisions de protection et de
confinement qui nécessitent des
dérogations pour les labels des aop isa
aussi puisque on est obligé de leur
garantir leurs ventes et en même temps
vous le savez dès qu'on abat on a des
lises c'est la règle et ça doit
s'appliquer
voilà monsieur le député aujourd'hui la
situation et voilà comment nous y
répondons merci